cinéma à partir d'aujourd'hui sur les
écrans le nouveau film de bertrand
tavernier autour de minuit l'histoire
d'un jeune homme dans les années 40 qui
se prend d'amitié pour un jazzman noirs
américains le film dure plus de deux
heures avec beaucoup de musique composée
par herbie hancock l'équipe du film
s'est retrouvé au célèbre petit journal
de montparnasse un club de jazz
voyez le reportage de nicole cornu
langlois est ivre
pour cette fête du jazz herbie hancock
était au piano il est compositeur
arrangeur et acteur dans ce film dédié à
bud powell et lester young et qui est un
acte d'amour pour le jazz mais surtout
pour ses musiciens savent que j'ai fait
est fait avec l'amour tous ces gens là
et avec une certaine forme de colère
parce que là ils ont été plutôt oublié
par le cinéma américain et j'avais envie
de
de réparer un peu cette injustice et les
gens qui m'ont inspiré m'ont beaucoup de
choses dans mon adolescence
qui m'ont donné envie de faire du cinéma
peut-être de créer
et le coup le goût de la liberté à la
fin des années 50 c'est l'amitié intense
entre bud powell interprété par
l'admirable dexter gordon est un jeune
admirateur passionné qui est à l'origine
de ce film dont on a donné le meilleur
de ma vie c'est une curieuse c'est d'une
puce chimie dans ma vie le jazz je l' ai
toujours écouté dans tout ce que j'ai
fait bouger le bout en bout à travailler
chez moi parce que j'étais dessinateur
comme le personnage du du film et cette
musique imprégnée complètement ma vie
c'est une sorte de d'oxygène
et quand l'interprète rencontre le
modèle c'est l'émotion quand on regarde
j'ai vu beaucoup de choses
ils m'ont vraiment bouleversée je crois
que le public se sent bien
place il a vu un truc c'était la mission
que j'avais c'est à dire comment aimer
votre powell comment aimer les stores
you comment aimer dexter puisque c'était
dexter en tant que figure humaine qui
était en face de moi mais dexter disait
tout le temps comment j'ai du mal à
jouer pour ce film parce qu'il faut que
je pense à buzz il faut que je pense à
lester donc ils étaient ils en avaient
plein jouer et moi aussi j'en avais
plein délire j'avais francis cha et ma
vie parce que
viel se calque sur un affront ce fut le
cas de toute une équipe liée pendant
trois mois de tournage par la passion du
jazz le jazz est une musique très
éclectique
parce qu'elle empruntait des musiques et
des périodes très différentes ce qui me
paraît le plus attractif c'est qu'elle
s'enrichit constamment qu'elle assimile
d'autres genres c'est une musique
vraiment vivante et ce film apporte
aussi un renouveau dans les liens
étroits et étrange entre le rock et le
jazz